ein foto ging um die welt ein us soldat
auf der mauer des flughafens in kabul
zieht ein baby an seinem arm hoch und
rettet es damit dem chaos nach der
machtübernahme durch die taliban
womöglich vor dem tod aber was muss es
für ein gefühl für die familie gewesen
sein ihr eigenes baby wegzugeben nicht
zu wissen ob man das kind jemals
wiedersieht wir werden es gleich
erfahren denn wir haben die familie
tatsächlich gefunden und mit ihnen
gesprochen dabei zuerst sprechen damit
bild reporter paul ronzheimer der in
afghanistan war in kabul war lange von
dort berichtet hat als du damals diese
bilder gesehen das was ist dir da durch
den kopf gegangen
das wahnsinnig nah gegangen dieses bild
zu sehen weil ich dort an der stelle war
schon sehr häufig vor in zeiten wo die
taliban noch nicht da war dass man dort
durchgefahren und zum flughafen zu
kommen und dann in den tagen als es
sozusagen die sind sturm auf den
flughafen gab war ich an diesem
flughafen
und ich habe ihn mir auch noch einmal
angeschaut vor wenigen wochen und wenn
man da jetzt vorbei geht wenn man da
vorbeifährt dann ist da immer noch diese
riesige explosionen die es dann gegeben
hat kurz nachdem dieses baby gerettet
wurde wir erinnern uns es gab ein
anschlag von eis ist also der
nachfolgeorganisation von ices und wie
viel glück dieses baby hatte dass es
überlebt hat dass es gerettet wurde
dass so viele andere immer noch fest
stecken in afghanistan das ist mir durch
den kopf gegangen beschreibt uns mal ein
bisschen die stimmung vor ort damals zu
diesem zeitpunkt das war ja alles sehr
hektisch sehr undurchsichtig keiner
wusste so richtig wie es weitergeht
keiner wusste wie es weitergeht keiner
wusste was die taliban tatsächlich tun
würden keiner wusste ob es direkt
massenhinrichtung geben würde jetzt muss
man sagen mit ein bisschen abstand
massenhinrichtung hat es nicht direkt
gegeben aber ich persönlich kenne
alleine drei leute die immer noch
vermisst sind also die
der angriff auf die menschen die gegen
die taliban stehen der passiert jeden
tag jede nacht menschen insbesondere
außerhalb kabuls plötzlich sind sie
verschwunden
mädchen so wie versprochen wurde dürften
zum großen teil immer noch nicht in die
schule gehen also all diese großen
versprechungen die es gegeben hat von
den taliban anführern auch die haben
sich nicht bestätigt wir sprechen gleich
weiter paul aber widmen wir uns zunächst
mal dem schicksal dieses baby ist nach
dem das bild um die welt ging und so
viele menschen berührte begann ja das
rätsel wer ist das wo sind die eltern
und wie kam es zu dieser dramatischen
szene unser usa-korrespondent herbert
bauernebel hat es für uns herausgefunden
vorne gebeugt erhebt ein baby an einer
hand über einen messerscharfen
stacheldrahtzaun das gesicht des kindes
ist durch das beharrliche weinen und
schreien verzerrt unter ihm verzweifelte
menschen zusammengedrängt einige schon
tot getrampelt es ist der 19 august in
kabul herrscht chaos die taliban haben
tage zuvor die macht in afghanistan
übernommen die lage eskaliert dramatisch
massenpanik das an der hand des marines
hängende baby einer der bewegendsten und
symbolträchtigsten momente des abzug
dramas festgehalten auf foto und video
gleich wird gerätselt wer ist das baby
wo sind seine eltern und wie kam es zu
dieser dramatischen szene die die ganze
welt zu erschütterte bild hat das baby
und die familie gefunden sie leben
gerade in einem vorort von phoenix im us
bundesstaat arizona in sicherheit und
freiheit und bild hat sie besucht ich
bin dem soldaten so dankbar für das was
er für uns getan hat er hat meine liga
gerettet ich würde ihnen gerne
persönlich dafür danken ein wunsch der
nachvollziehbar ist denn dass die
rettung der kleinen familie überhaupt
möglich war ein glücksfall hamid der
vater des babys arbeitet am flughafen in
kabul hilft dort im us marines beim
umstrittenen afghanistan am zug als sich
die lage in afghanistan zuspitzt
beschwört er seine frau zur flucht sei
der pakt ausweise schmuck und geld ein
und eilt mit dem baby zum flughafen an
einem checkpoint wird ja alles
abgenommen trotzdem gelingt es die am
airport in kabul anzukommen
hektischen menschen mehr vor dem zorn
sie damit seine frau und das baby ruft
sie verzweifelt doch seit er fällt immer
wieder in ohnmacht weil sie noch
mitgenommen ist von der schweren geburt
der kurs des vaters ansa die us seite
nimmt das neugeborene und hippes hoch
ein us marines zieht es an der hand über
den zaun auch sei der kann kurz darauf
gerettet werden gemeinsam fliegt die
familie in die vereinigten staaten
obwohl sie jetzt in sicherheit sind gibt
es denn noch große herausforderungen sei
die erwartet auf ausweise und
reisepapiere vermied ist etwa 1500
kilometer von seiner frau und seinem
baby entfernt sie wohnt in phoenix er in
texas arbeitet in einem militär
flüchtlingszentrum über eine
spendenseite sind bereits knapp 70.000
us dollar für die familie
zusammengekommen für einen neuanfang
sadia hofft
ich möchte zuerst die englische sprache
lernen dann würde ich gerne mit meinem
mann zusammen arbeiten aber eigentlich
will ich erzieherin werden ich liebe
kinder und wollte schon immer erzieherin
sein das ist mein ziel sie hofft auch
dass sich die frauenrechte in
afghanistan in zukunft wieder verbessern
damit sie ihr heimatland besuchen können
wird wenn sie älter ist und
[Musik]
wir schauen jetzt zu unserem bild
korrespondenten in die usa herbert
bauernebel herbert schönen guten tag wie
hast du es geschafft diese familie das
baby zu finden
eine große vorarbeit hat eine örtliche
tv station in arizona geleistet die
einen beitrag gemacht hat über dieses
über diese familie die es in die usa
geschafft hat ich habe dann über einen
fundraiser dem vater hamid kontaktiert
und nach einigen e mails nach einer
geduld und ausdauer hat er sich
zurückgemeldet er sagte er möchte das
interview machen möchte die
weltöffentlichkeit aufmerksam machen auf
das schicksal der menschen in
afghanistan auch wenn er dabei natürlich
ein wenig ein risiko eingeht denn seine
familie ist nach wie vor in afghanistan
großteils wie auch ihre familie und das
ist natürlich ein risiko wenn man hier
in der welt öffentlichkeit auftritt du
hast das gesagt hat du hast mit dem
vater gesprochen wird er auf dich
gewirkt nach dieser flucht nach diesem
schicksal
der vater ist sehr es wirklich ein sehr
solider herzlicher mann der hier auch zu
rückblick auf diese schreckens stunden
als er eben seine frau gesehen hat vor
dem diesen ball dieser hat dieser mauer
in dieser menge
zusammengedrängt
sengender hitze natürlich auch die
amerikaner haben versucht die leute
zurückzudrängen es gab tränengas und
blendgranaten und
draußen eben seine frau diese momente
das spürt man schon wenn man mit ihm
spricht sind haben ein kleines trauma
ausgelöst als er teilweise auch hilflos
war auch nach dem moment als das baby
dann schon gerettet war er sagte dann zu
mir hätte sich mehrmals niedersetzen
müssen auf dem boden seine augen
schließen müsse müssen dann hätte er
wieder hinaus geschaut auf die menge wo
seine frau jetzt ist und das ganze hat
insgesamt 15 stunden gedauert die
rettung des seines babys und seiner frau
das spürt man schon bei ihr ist es auch
ähnlich sie spricht auch immer wieder
über diese momente in kabul aber
natürlich für diese familie ist es ein
happy end wenn auch die sorge um ihre
eigenen familien nach wie vor groß ist
man kann sich schon vorstellen wie sehr
diese flucht und wie sehr diese sorge
auch die menschen mitnimmt herbert jetzt
haben wir schon im beitrag gesehen die
junge mutter möchte perspektivisch
irgendwann mal erzieherin werden aber
wie geht's jetzt kurzfristig für die
familie weiter
das ist eine schwierige situation werden
sie auch sehr gut untergekommen ist die
mutter und das kind leben in einem sehr
schönen haus in einem vorort von phoenix
sind hier bei verwandten untergekommen
bestens betreut der vater hamit hat
sofort mit der arbeit begonnen die sagte
arbeitet in einem dieser prozess im
centers der amerikanischen streitkräfte
hierauf kümmert sich hier offensichtlich
um afghanen die gerade angekommen sind
in den usa arbeitet dort sieben tage die
woche 14 stunden schichten sein
hauptziel wie er mir gesagt hat ist
jetzt so viel geld wie möglich zu
verdienen einfach um zu versuchen seine
und ihre familie herauszubringen aus
afghanistan die schwester seiner frau
sie leidet an blutkrebs sie braucht
medizinische behandlung sein eigener
bruder und seinen eigenen verwandten
waren bei der polizei und beim
geheimdienst alle alle sind sehr
gefährdet sie würden sich auch der zeit
verstecken habe es geheißen das ist
jetzt das hauptziel
in länger längerfristig hat er gesagt
dass er möglicherweise als als
übersetzer arbeiten möchte oder
vielleicht sogar als lkw fahrer aus das
hat er gemacht die familie plant hier
ihre zukunft in den usa um das ist schon
sehr bewegend wenn sie einem das
erzählen ganz kurz nachher warum neben
den beiden nicht zusammen
das ist wegen dem job des vaters des
ehemannes der jetzt wie gesagt in wiesen
in diesem militäranlage dienst versieht
deswegen sind sie getrennt es ist nur
bis baut jetzt nur noch vielleicht zwei
drei wochen für diesen job beim kann das
wiedersehen sie telefonieren sie
versuchen mit facetime sich
auszutauschen sie schickt dem immer
wieder fotos vom baby- und für sie
selbst da ergibt sagt wie sie sagt gibt
er das baby die ganze kraft hierdurch zu
kommen durch diese schwierige zeit
herbert bauernebel unserer
korrespondentin den usa
danke für den bericht
all das gehört die familie hofft jetzt
natürlich auch darauf dass ihren
verwandten ihren freunden noch geholfen
wäre die alle noch in afghanistan in
kabul fest sitzen wie schätzt du die
wahrscheinlichkeit ein dass das noch
passiert dass er noch weitere menschen
rausgeholt werden können die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass man es sozusagen
auf flieger der internationalen
gemeinschaft irgendwie schafft dies sehr
sehr gering also da gibt es kaum
möglichkeiten
ich bekomme immer wieder nachrichten
auch von leuten die für die deutsche
armee gearbeitet haben fürs auswärtige
amt die dort sehr panisch sind die
meisten die versuchen rauszukommen die
versuchen sozusagen auf illegalem wege
erst mal in den iran also die versuchen
sich ein visum zu holen in den iran und
nach pakistan und dann von dort
sozusagen die weiterreise zu schaffen
denn wenn man eine ja wenn man legal
sozusagen in die usa oder nach
deutschland darf dann ist das problem
das ist momentan afghanistan überhaupt
eine botschaft gibt wo man hingehen
könnte aber das ist natürlich ein also
cairns ein bisschen auch das ist ja
wahnsinnig beschwerlicher weg da über
diesen landweg wenn man kleine kinder
dabei hat das ist ja kaum möglich oder
das ist ein beschwerlicher weg wobei man
sagen muss dass vereinzelt auch wieder
flugzeuge fliegen aber das kostet viel
viele menschen können sich das nicht
leisten das problem ist auch dass die
humanitäre situation auf dann wirklich
dramatisch wird es gibt berichte wie
frauen verkauft werden dort wie kinder
unterernährt sind und das nimmt
dramatisch zu paulmann man hat ja den
eindruck ein gefühl das man nicht mehr
viel hört momentan aus kabul hat sich
die lage beruhigt oder schauen wir
einfach nicht mehr hin wir schauen nicht
mehr so hin wie wir hinschauen sollten
ich glaube das ist natürlich auch ein
bisschen normaler reflex nach vielen
vielen wochen und vielen krisenherden
auf der welt und vielen verschiedenen
themen das die menschen irgendwie müde
werden und wir bei bild versuchen das
unter anderem durch eine dokumentation
die wir jetzt bei bild tv gezeigt haben
aber auch online gestellt haben und
somit machtwechsel wo wir verschiedene
menschen begleitet haben über einen sehr
langen zeitraum immer wieder ins
blickfeld der menschen zu rücken und ich
werde ganz sicher auch noch einmal in
diesem jahr nach afghanistan fliegen
[Musik]